good morning gamers what up Steuben
who's a good boy today we are building
something special for my minecraft dog I
don't know exactly what we're gonna pill
but that's the fun of Minecraft
isn't that right Sven that's right I've
been messing around a lot with you with
redstone I have a lot of fun doing it
and I finally learned how to build
robots and stuff like that so I want to
build a giant robot for my for my dog I
don't know if this will work but that's
the fun of it that's the part of it what
I do know is how to build a leg
mechanism in Minecraft
with redstone okay gamers and it's
actually really cool and really easy so
we're just gonna do that bling blang
blang you do a bling blang blang see if
I remember and you do a bling blang
blang and then bling this will all make
sense you have to do the sound effects
otherwise it doesn't work this needs to
go here and then this needs to go here
and it's goes here and there you go
there we have a leg doesn't look like
much of a leg does its fame cool the
basic gist of it is you'll have a piston
pushing here and voila this goes up
which activates this piston which pushed
it pushes it forward which gives us like
robot like leg movement very cool which
means of course we can build you
something very adorable sent about we do
this orange like the honey block and
we'll build you a little kitty cat how
about that Sven you like kid the cat's
well hope will build Sven and giant
elaborate that look house man he's so
impressed he can't wait I mean other
than that it's pretty simple you just
need said no stop you need something to
just push this basically 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11
can we put a boat here and put spend in
the boat yes oh I'm getting the boat
get in the boat son I ask a question all
right fine you can get in the boat I'll
make sure it's safe then we just need to
add a motor to it I'll use that we'll
hit the ones I use it works okay they'll
make fun of me all right
bing bang bong and then we just need it
swen is in spend is ready to ride oh god
this is dangerous I'll do a backup this
friend will not die here we go all right
so when you're ready to ride go
I forgot the redstone and go
be safe Sven
yes it's like a bunny Oh God haha he
loved said don't you love it then it's
like a weird horse looking thing isn't
it
[Music]
yeah
yeah onwards spend
you're looking in the wrong direction
but this is so cool
[Music]
okay time to stop time to stop yay I'm
so glad you made it safe what does that
look like I'm trying to figure out like
what animal I should bill for him maybe
I'll ask him Twitter a lot of people are
saying tanks a lot of people are saying
the moving doghouse that's so buddy so
this is cool and all it's very basic
it's when lumps in the problem I have it
with it is that it's walking like this I
don't like that I want one leg one leg
one leg you understand me and to do that
we need a different type of motor
spending is on top of this literally the
Redstone community on YouTube is so cool
everyone is building such amazing things
I'll link some of the videos that I use
to learn how to do stuff just in case
here oh my god saved [ __ ] hey come dance
me that's right so this is a three step
motor this will activate this one and
then this will activate this one in this
so each leg at a time will it be
activated wait did I do it upside down I
don't know what it is with redstone as'
is so addicting why is a redstone
addictive it makes no sense okay so
so I built this yesterday but it's I
don't know it doesn't always work so
we'll see how this goes
Oh God like that so this activates this
this is stuck to this so this activates
the this and then this activates this so
it will be one leg at a time it'll be
epic but we also got to make sure that
it powers itself isn't that right Sven
yes see which will do like this and then
connect it with slime three two one go
oh don't ever do that again you scare my
meat it is it shower you would love now
this is the fun stuff this is the fun
stuff come on it will be epic and we
just need to add something to make it
push we shouldn't be too bad we just put
that there right that isn't really that
easy
oh my gold let's try it you see one leg
two leg one leg two legs epic so n is
following because he knows it's gonna be
awesome
so let's build our little little Smith
the legs I just realized I want to build
it higher up god
and what big legs cuz that's what I have
in real life I don't even care his leg
looks so dumb
okay Japan let's build the other leg
let's make sure they work
oh god it's fine you're very close to
that all right who's ready to test out
this thing let's freakin do this did I
forget to connect them again every time
oh okay
look it's walking dance legs I finally
made yeah they're beautiful
I finally had links it's the most
happiest day of my life never been their
proud event is so happy for me as well
Mike
what there's legs in Minecraft oh yeah
yeah run over him kill him kill him
destroy destroy damn it
creeper creeper is equally disappointed
I'm starting to realize in just the
absolute grind the absolute grind for
Redstone engineers like Jesus all right
I do want to build a can so let's see
how I would do that well this turned out
a lot more complicated than I thought
okay it's fine I don't care
think I'm running out of brainpower I
don't know what happened to me this
should not be that difficult this is so
convoluted I cannot believe it
and it doesn't work either so that's
always good I think this will work did
it who knows
god it's so big is it no it's not
working
did it work I think it is working I
might as well make it in a horse at this
point because that's what it looks like
anyway this is the front paw
did I delete the motor
oh I deleted the motor by accident I
don't think that's supposed to happen I
don't even know what I'm looking at
anymore I'm trying to recreate what I
made I did not expect to be a little bit
freaking Oh God
the effort smash like on this video for
the effort the absolute effort what is
this it should work yeah so I'm pretty
sure I've never spent this much effort
on anything in my entire life I thought
this would be an easy little pill that's
becoming very very very very convoluted
it stays it's so ugly oh all right I
don't like a face
god damn do I have a lot of regrets
absolutely but is it too late to go back
now yeah that's that's the situation
we're in here I am very very cautiously
optimistic that this is gonna work but I
do want to try it so here we go
[Music]
it took a couple steps oh god I can't
stop I just like I can't stop I'm so oh
[Music]
my god it's beautiful
what is this wow it's a holy creature oh
[Music]
okay
we're almost done we're almost at I can
do this I can do this it is a Shannon
both
[Music]
okay so this will be the command center
and then now we just have to connect
this last bit one all right it's time so
then I know you've been very patient
come out of there wake up yes that's
right I've got a present for you swing I
need you to get in the boat like we
practiced
come on Spain hey you are ask my boy get
in the boat oh oh yes he's backwards
[Music]
why are you backwards is the boat
backwards don't be sad don't be scared
don't be scared here we go
I'm sorry what did I do wrong
finally
[Music]
well let me clear the way said I made
God in Minecraft gamers he loves said he
loves it
this is me my boy we started off trying
to blow up tea and tea and here we are
boys we made it to the top spin we made
it did it that there you go then then
look at me are you happy
look what I made you it's a it's a giant
event for swain it so cute Sven loves it
you're welcome Spain oh it's still going
spend goes forever I need to feel like a
weapon for him or something maybe I'll
do that next time
where's the back legs the back legs are
so far away can we see the whole thing
in motion
all right smash like if you enjoyed this
video if you want if you have any
suggestions what I should build for Sven
next airplane helicopter let me know and
I'll be sure to build it this is a lot
of fun i genuinely had a lot of fun
why is it so scary Jeff laughs ah you
haven't played PewDiePie pixel in yet
you clearly don't understand the game is
so great
hold on two chairs it might even make
tuber simulator irrelevant and it's free
check it out
[Music]